What happens when you place a credit card
into SCP-914, or The Clockworks?
Dr. Naismith decided to find out.
Dr. Naismith placed his credit card into SCP-914
on the setting "Very Fine."
The output was a similar-looking credit card,
printed with the phrase "RANK-ALEPH INFINITE
MONEY PRIVILEGES."
Dr. Naismith received a note reading:
"Dr. Naismith, I didn’t think I need to
remind you that SCP-914 is not to be used
for personal financial gain, but it seems
I was wrong.
Consider this an official warning.
-Dr. Coltrane"
He placed the note itself into the Clockworks,
on the setting "Very Fine."
The machinery produced a note that instead
read: "Dr. Naismith, I didn’t even think
of using SCP-914 for personal financial gain,
but that seems like a solid idea.
Consider this official permission to reap
the fruits of your labor.
-O5-11”